[Music]
[Applause]
John kenzano longtime Oregon columnist
and you can find him at John kenzo.com
has been following the story as well all
right so what happened in The Newsroom
or I should say courtroom of uh you know
with the Pack 12 with Oregon State and
Washington State well it was really
interesting to be in there because you
have this small town feeli in kfax less
than 3,000 people there you've got the
judge's wife sitting over in the jury
box you got former Washington State
coach Jim Walton sitting next to her
their family friends they had lunch
together before the hearing so there's
all this uh this really folksy stuff
going on in the courtroom and then you
have these attorneys that are making
$600 an hour who are you know it's like
15 attorneys that are in the room and
they're in a tug ofwar over the board
seats in the pack2 conference and the
judge judge liby Gary liby he ultimately
ruled that the actions of of the board
in the last year you know they kicked
UCLA and USC off the board when they
announced they were going to the big 10
they kicked Colorado off when they said
they were going to the big 12 he said
hey that action matters uh that's how
you acted and he you know yesterday
awarded the two board seats to Oregon
State and Washington State now there's
going to be appeals they're going to
file a uh you know a motion with the
state supreme court today the departing
10 schools will file that motion they're
going to ask for a stay of the judge's
temporary restraining order and they're
going to try to find some more favorable
terrain to uh to argue this case they'll
probably go to the uh to Olympia the
state capital there in Washington
unbelievable what do you think the Pack
12 is going to look like well I think
ultimately organ State and Washington
State they they want to rebuild this
thing you know the the president at
Washington state was in the courtroom
two athletic directors were in the
courtroom they want to get busy
rebuilding it and the 10 departing
schools are really stalling this out
they know the transfer portal window is
December 4th they know that's kind of a
drop dead moment and so I think they're
really trying to squeeze those two
schools because they would the departing
schools want all the money they want to
take their share of the money they want
to dissolve the conference um you know
there's $420 million in Revenue coming
in this year this fiscal year there's
about another 170 coming in in future
years so there's a lot of money at stake
here Oregon State and Washington State
want to use that money to rebuild the
departing schools want to take their
share and and be done with it and so
that's really what this is about okay
you need a new commissioner for the Pack
12 or whatever it's going to be called
and you need a TV deal so yeah the
likelihood of all of that happening here
before next season I guess the
commissioner would be the easy part what
about the TV deal how attractive would
that be yeah I think they have to buy
some time you know and I talked there's
two paths really for Oregon State and
Washington State I don't think they try
to do this in you know 2024 I think what
they try to do is next season they're
going to play as a conference of two
that's that's I keep hearing that over
and over and the two paths that are
available to them are a they put
together a 12 game schedule they try to
uh live off the media rights money and
the what they win in this court case for
the next couple of years and then they
really focus on 2025 the alternate path
if they're not able to put together a
schedule and I'm told that they already
have modeled that they have you know
they could successfully put together a
12-game schedule but the more favorable
one might just be to create a scheduling
partnership or an alliance with the
Mountain West Conference Place some of
those schools in 2025 there's still a
whole bunch of other schools out there
like Utah Cal and Stanford who are
looking for games I think you could pick
up some power five games but I don't
know you're right about the TV money I
don't know what that deal could look
like in 2024 but that's why the money
that's wrapped up in the conference and
in this court proceeding is so important
because Oregon State and Washington
State are going to have to live off of
that for about 18 to 24 months but then
legally if you restructure the Pack 12
but it's called The Pack 12 can you
still get the automatic birth the winner
of the Pack 12 you know playing for a
national championship yeah that's a
really important question and I think
there's a debate to be had there and
there may be in a negotiation you know
Kirk Schultz the president of Washington
state is on that Council he holds a vote
in that in that decision on that
President's Council so I think he could
leverage that I think really though too
the other thing I've heard is you know
if you do Cobble together the Pack 12
and you bring it back and you keep the
brand and I think they will do that you
could argue that if they add the right
schools Dan that it becomes the best
group of five and that conference
champion in most years probably gets a
birth anyway even though it's not
automatic so you know this is about you
know I keep hearing this over and over
from Washington State and Oregon State
it's about survival in the next two
years and then what happens to college
football and can their brands and their
success on the football field help them
uh be part of whatever comes next we
know that uh Colorado needs to have six
wins according to the the Pack 12
guidelines to be bull eligible well if
the regular season ends and they have
five wins are they still affiliated with
the Pack 12 is the foot like can they
are they already seceding from the union
now they're in limbo now they could go
to a bowl game with only five wins not
the the requisite six yeah I think the
love language of College athletics is
always going to be money I think if uh
if Colorado can justify that there is
windfall that the conference would share
in because technically nobody's leaving
until August 1 of 2024 uh if they could
convince the conference hey there's a
windfall here there's a network that's
willing to pay there's a bowl game
that's willing to pay for Colorado to be
part of it which there should be I think
that the uh the board now made of two uh
could get together and say hey we're we
would lower that requirement and a five
team win uh you know five win team could
get into a bowl game great to talk to
you John uh thanks for following this
story thanks Dan that's John kenzano
longtime Oregon columnist radio host you
can follow him at John keno.com